Take a look at THESE SAGGY BANANAS,
BITCH!
(screaming)
(laughter)
Sank you to Audible.com for
sponsoring today's episode!
Really Anna? An Ad?
Unsellable..
Way to sell out.
I hate you, sell out!
She sold out.
What a sell out.
Sell out.
Sell out!
What a fucking sell out.
Did you know that the word "sell out"
is used exclusively for people
in the entertainment industry?
Isn't that weird, considering that
it's also the hardest industry
to make a living in?
And normally, when people get promoted,
we celebrate.
We like, throw them parties.
Surprise!
We're all so excited because it's a sign
that they're doing well.
My boss offered me a big promotion at work today.
Oh babe, that's great!
Maybe we can look into buying a house next year.
I didn't take it, Brad.
What do you think I am?
A fucking sell out?
I'm an insurance...ARTIST.
Even when athletes get sponsored by a brand,
or sign contracts for millions of dollars,
no one goes up to them and says,
"You're only in it for the money!"
That's not true!
Although, thank you Ghost and Stars for sponsoring
today's episode. Ghostandstars.com.
I've been thinking about this a lot lately,
and, ultimately I've come to the conclusion that
"Sell out" is all perception.
So, the only important thing is...
Do I feel like a sell out?
Sure.
If a sell out is someone that
puts high value on their work,
then sure.
If a sell out is someone who
recognizes that money frees up your time
to work on non-paying passion projects,
awesome.
If a sell out is someone who loves what they do,
but also wants to make a living at it,
then yeah.
Honestly, I'm so sick of the whole
"Starving artist" idea.
And I know it's so cliche to say,
so I'll say it with a beard.
It's called "show business."
Don't just work hard. Work smart.
You didn't sell out.
You bought in.
To being a wizard.
I'm Anna Akana.
You stay awesome.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara